You guys,
Tim Ferriss here,
author of the four hour body.
I wanted to show you some new tricks that I've picked up in the last few years.
This one was related to hamstring flexibility.
I have notoriously terrible hamstring mobility.
We just can't even touch the ground.
My legs bent type of issues.
And the first time I was ever in a yoga class and other guys considered me the
flexible dude was after doing zero yoga.
It was after doing a combination of exercises,
it's probably six to eight,
but I'll show you two of them that had a particularly large impact and I want to
give credit where credit is due.
These are directly from Jersey Grigorik.
You have to look this guy up.
He's incredible checkout some of these videos on youtube as a four time or five
time Olympic weightlifting world champion.
He is in his sixties and is still more mobile and stronger than I am.
And a can do everything cold.
He's incredible.
The program that he created is called the happy body,
so you can look up uh,
Gregorick Jersey,
Gregorick,
Greg O,
r e k.
Grigorik.
And,
uh,
definitely take a look.
But these are two that I found very helpful.
And a,
you should look at the entire program though because it does piece together very
well.
So the first is,
uh,
is as follows.
We're going to be on your back and uh,
this is a hamstring stretch,
but it's also an abdominal exercise of sorts.
And of course I'm probably not doing this perfectly,
but I'll show you what has helped me in any case.
So I'm going to come here and arms are overhead.
I'm going to take an inhale,
I'm going to finish my terminal knee extension,
pull my toes back and I'll,
I'll demonstrate first.
So Watch,
okay,
so I'm only going to do six or so.
Reps did that.
Now,
a few key components here.
You want your legs to oh,
totally straight as straight as possible.
So you're going to have to contract your vastus medialis and your quads to
really lock it toes back.
And when you come up,
I did add one little thing to this,
uh,
which is probably,
some type of sacrilege,
but I will go as far as I can hook.
And then I'll bring my hips back,
almost like what's called a pipe pulse in gymnastics.
So I'll do that.
Six reps,
that's it.
And in that Max Range,
I'm only staying there for a half second to a second.
It's very,
very short.
Okay.
That's exercise one.
Literally I might do one set of those in the morning.
Okay.
And then I would do other exercises for low back squat,
et Cetera,
uh,
which Jersey prescribes.
So you should take a look at the full program,
but the other hamstring specific exercise and he has many that I found very
helpful is using dumbbells.
And uh,
there are a number of different variations of this,
but you'll notice I have a wide stance.
My toes are pointing out and I'll show you what you want to try to do.
And I may not execute this perfectly,
but you do not want to round at the back or particularly the low back.
This is a hamstring stretch.
So you want it to kind of lead with your gut,
if that makes sense.
Lead with your lower abdomen.
So you're going to be here.
Same breathing sequence.
I'm taking a big breath in stretch completely exercise.
Exhale,
this is what it looks like,
and I'm pulling my toes back.
Okay,
so straight legs again,
that's one rep,
that's it.
So you're not spending a lot of time again at that Max end of your range.
It's very,
very brief.
And I will typically just go down for it again,
a half a second,
maybe quarter second at most a second.
So it looks like this
toes back,
legs completely contracted,
not this
up.
And then shrug
down.
Exhale.
That's the second rep.
You do five or six of that.
That's it.
Okay.
Now Jersey would most likely have you go through multiple rounds of this.
Uh,
and I would agree that that is ideal,
but in a very rushed situation,
in the morning of five minutes,
you can get a lot out of those two exercises.
Um,
but please give credit to Jersey and check out his program.
So Jersey Grigorik again,
j e R,
Z y Olympic lifting.
If you just search that,
you'll find tons and tons on him.
Uh,
do me a favor and get his book or the DVDs.
He's incredible.
One of the most amazing teachers I've ever met.
So there you have it.
Hope those help.
If you enjoyed that video,
let's talk about a list.
Arnold Schwarzenegger,
Jamie Foxx,
undisputed King of Big Wave Surfing.
Laird Hamilton.
The list goes on and on.
What do they have in common?
They're sharing their secrets,
their morning routines,
favorite books,
everything with me on my podcast,
the Tim Ferriss show,
70 million plus downloads,
iTunes,
best of 2015 check it out.
You will not be disappointed.